- Taylor, you're from Pennsylvania,
but after 10 years being
in Chicago regularly,
do you feel like a Chicagoan now?
- Yeah, I mean, like you said,
it's been almost a decade.
We're in season nine.
I do get a lot of,
if I get recognized, it's
mostly from my character.
- Well, has just being on "Chicago Fire"
helped you get out of any jams
with Chicago law enforcement?
Have you pulled the card?
- I haven't like, I haven't
really pulled the card.
Like I have met and know a
lot of first responders now,
just because of, you know, proximity.
But I do have a story.
I was on my motorcycle, it
was raining, it was cold.
The traffic was really, really bad.
This was maybe two years ago.
And so I hopped off onto the median
to the right side and just
started passing all the traffic,
all the cars
in what would be either
a bus or service lane.
A cop car gets behind me, sees me,
puts the lights on, pulls me over.
I think I'm, you know, gonna
get ticketed and trouble.
Police officer walks up,
I take off my helmet,
and he's like, "Oh, it's you,
the fake firefighter."
And we kinda laughed and had a chuckle.
I think he made fun of
me for a little bit,
which is fine 'cause then he let me go.
He just said, "Get home safe,
don't do that again,
and I like the show."
So that, you know, that's my
get out of jail free card.
- That's awesome.
That's amazing.
You just take your helmet
off, and it's handled.
That's amazing. (laughs)